frau carrasco am sonntag waren
hunderttausende auf den straßen
unterwegs aber lukaschenko ist immer
noch präsident scheiterte revolution so
ich würde das nicht als revolution
nennen
und ich denke und ich sage das immer
auch wenn man danach nicht in meine ganz
wichtige message ist das alles was wir
jetzt machen ist es ein prozess um diese
prozess waren diese wird gesellschaft
sich selber einbauen und es ist wirklich
passiert nicht in einem tag und das
wissen wir dass es in separaten und da
sagen wir auch alle leuten weil
natürlich manche haben auch frustration
aber wir müssen einfach jeden tag
arbeiten
jetzt sieht man auf den straßen wieder
neue festnahmen
dass die sicherheitsdienste sind wieder
präsenter geworden und dem schloss und
es gab auch aus ihrem koordinierungsrat
festnahm
wie gehen sie damit um heißt das über
schein vom forschungsbereich
zuzuschlagen
natürlich die würden jetzt noch die
versuchen jetzt natürlich noch mehr
angst verbreiten im gesellschaft das
wirkt aber gegen ja weil die leute
verstehen was passiert um natürlich wenn
sie haben diese freiheitsvirus bekommen
die würden das nie vergessen und
zweitens auch alle erfahrungen die sehen
die gewählte gerade die festnahmen vor
zwei wochen am 9
august und viele leute hätten das
überhaupt nicht akzeptieren und sich
natürlich die frage von zeit wie wir
würden das nehmen und in welche richtung
würden wir das als volk auch sagen dass
die müssen alle die das gemacht haben so
soll gewaltigen die müssen selber
hingefahren
jetzt ziehen nebenfrau kija oscar die
leute mit autisten personen dieser
bewegung derweil auch im ausland unter
sich das immer noch frei sind
ich schulde ich wundere mich schon seit
dreieinhalb monaten gilt dass ich frei
bin aber ich finde der frage ist nicht
so korrekt weil jeder in bilanzierte
eine von oder jene von neun millionen
bevölkerung seien belarus könnten jeden
tag festgenommen sein und das wissen wir
alle dass erstmals gesehen haben haben
sie gesagt es sei noch zu früh für
sanktionen haben sie das gefühl dass sie
langsam von der europäischen seite ist
es mit aber daran dass draußen dass
europa jetzt reagieren müsste ich denke
dass wir hier selber in terrorismus
müssen alle möglicher aber ernte von der
druck auf regierung nehmen natürlich und
für uns ist auch sehr wichtig dass wir
vielleicht erst mal in die geschichte
mit unserer hände würden diese
demokratie und diese freiheit irgendwie
entwicklung hier ja und das ist ganz
wichtig natürlich ist es auch wichtig
dass die eu und internationale familie
uns unterstützt aber ganz wichtig dass
wir selber auch diese verantwortung
tragen für unsere zukunft gitarre
geschenkt hat sich eine stunde gezahlt
was bedeutet es sollte uns alles war
sehr irritierend und wir sehen das als
ein schlechtes hollywood film oder so
wenn ein komischer man mit komische
kleidung und mit komische kalaschnikow
im zentrum von minsk sämtliche staaten
von europa so irgendwas springt wie
schluckte und bricht mit seinem amon mit
seinem militärdienst
und natürlich wir sind alle so gelassen
und so wichtig weil man kann hat
überhaupt keine ahnung was er
weitermachen kann
haben sie keine angst nein ich bin
sicher dass er hat angst die einzige
mensch in burgers der hat angst das ist
lukaschenko deswegen ärgert kalaschnikow
und militärdienst in seiner umgebung
versehen zylinder eingespritzt
danke sehr
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren